jetzt kommt die nächste einheit die wir
uns vorgenommen haben geht es jetzt auch
um das thema lernen können und das ist
insofern wichtig als man aber davon
ausgehen muss dass das publikum die
studierenden die man vor sich hat wie
homogen sind wir haben schon einige
heterogenität der angesprochene also zum
beispiel in alter zusammensetzung
dadurch erkenntnisstand der
verschiedenen teilnehmern als es gibt
verschiedene und stumpfen verschiedene
gerade und jedes ergebnis auf
verschiedenen lehrern und das sollte man
nicht außer acht lassen dass er ein
bisschen von der position des
studierenden wir ein sturm aufzieht und
es gibt zum beispiel den visuellen job
die visuelle chip die sich vorstellen
können wird eben lernen durch israel
inputs visuelle wahrnehmung
das kann es lesen texte seien das kann
es betrachter von schaubildern seien von
zeugnissen logos die hoch
das können aber auch den statistiken ist
das heißt meint mehr beste methode des
wide webs es besonders gut geeignet
haben auch lern post alles was farben
und formen linien graf in bildern das
ist sehr sehr gut und jahre helfen neben
büchern skizzen bilder leeren tor wusste
videos nicht zu vergessen videos bewegte
bilder wirken stehende bilder lernt
parteien des handballs unter texten
farbliche hervorhebung das wichtige von
weniger wichtigen was eine sehr wichtige
kompetenz ist in dieser heutigen
datenflut sich zu orientieren da spielen
visuelle eine große rolle
ich denke bei den meisten von uns werden
und so einen großen anteil des visuellen
den chips haben mit uns das heißt es ist
sicher richtig
standard was man da recht viel
aufmerksamkeit darauf legt aber nicht zu
vernachlässigen ist auch die auditive
dimension des lernens man sagt immer zb
auch bei videos die man die wir jetzt
hier live streams seien die tonqualität
viel wichtiger als die videoqualität an
also dem motto qualität stimmt was bp
hoffen
es tut dann ist das bild gar nicht mal
so wichtig dann sicherlich wichtig weil
eben auch informationen durch das gehör
wie mir scheint noch direkter durch die
sprache nicht nur verfasstheit direkten
zugang zu unserem gehirn haben als
visuelle weil es weder zeichen zwar
nicht unbedingt über semantische
strukturiert sind sprachliche zeichen
vielleicht schon mal bilder nicht
unbedingt während die in akustische
signale wenn es gesprochen ist uns
direkt erreichen additive lernten wir
klären 10 gleich zu hören
sie kommen deswegen wie auch der
visuelle lernt wird mit dem klassischen
frontalunterricht sehr gut zurecht
politi verlernt sollten diese texte laut
gewesen
europa braucht natürlich auch eine
konzentration zu werten dass akustische
ungestört der cnc lernt kassetten oder
der videos werden sie dieses gespräche
vor
und auch musik sowas wird diese wichtig
wir haben also ein klarer ton der ruhige
situation
das ist immer schon gegeben wenn sie vom
tal unterricht haben
da steht jemand kartieren powerpoint
präsentation und sank dann zu gast also
in der regel werden diese zwei werden
typen schon angesprochen wenn vielleicht
auch über dieselben kanäle und auch hier
kann man innerhalb des jeweiligen
lehrern tipps variationen anträge die
man eben andere visuelle reize aus mit
als üblich in einer solchen
präsentationen zum beispiel haben im
internet einen live stream oder ein
youtube video fasst man verliert und
verschickt abspielt im studienseminar
dann gibt es aber noch andere den motor
bestückt und der wird heute von
nachlässt
da kann man zwar ist das prinzip
learning by doing utopische wert
schöpfen müssen es selbst mal versucht
haben und sie brauchen auch bewegungen
und sie können sich überlegen
es gibt dann verschicken wer mit schon
wieder von frage kommt eigentlich alle
wenn man mal aufstehen muss und sie
bewegen ist das ist grundsätzlich für
motor
der sehr gut zum beispiel auch wenn man
dann was die tafel schreiben mit dem
interaktiven meint ein farbiges papier
karton selbst beschriften nach vorne
bringen hing pillen mit disco gehen sich
hinsetzen
das ist was der typ sehr gut aus eine
grafik zur stadt erstellen toaster zu
erstellen etwas an die tafel zu
schreiben kann bewegungen mit lernen zu
koordinieren das ist für die sehr
wichtig gruppenaktivitäten natürlich
brauche und nicht zu vergessen wolle
mitspielen partner vielleicht auch
komplexere gruppen methoden wie diese
fische oder sowas werden vielleicht
eines notorischen besser gibt es im
kommunikativen lernstoff für die nächste
sprechen und hand und sehr wichtig es
geht es ein bisschen die richtung des
historischen und die es in die
diskussion sehr wichtig und der höhe
nicht zu gerne zu sondern er möchte auch
etwas sagen möchte selbst aktiv werden
und mitdiskutieren
und das ist an sich sehr gut da wird
sich mehr haben wird auch schätzen
dialoge diskussion der frage anfang an
spielen
das werden wir eben tage in diesem
zusammenhang passiert auch waren können
interessante methode die jetzt hin und
ganz aufgeht zeigt war ist ein quiz also
machen kann
sie können gruppenarbeiten form eines
quiz machen und zwar eignet sich so
ungewiss sehr gute als einstieg also
ausrichten abrücken weil sie sich schon
mal so ein bisschen testen und zwar die
studierenden untereinander wo stehen sie
zum beispiel der logik könnte man also
test machen und anschlüsse an geben und
sagen welches ist der falsche schluss
und es ist harte arbeit dass die
selbsternannte ausmachen können dann
wird zentralisiert und die kommunikation
zu verlieren genau als das sind die
werte die in aller kürze gehen dastehen
wollte also visuelle auditive typ
notorische tun und kommunikative typen
nicht vergessen immer versuche möglichst
viele kanäle anzusprechen weil es selten
nur dem einen typ als niemand von ihnen
wird nur dem eindruck zu gerechnet
werden können sie werden wie schon sein
ausscheiden anteil überlegen sie sich
mal vor
ich gerade auch mal jetzt während ich
präsentiere sich und schob sie sich
zählen oder überlebensgroße eigentlich
gehören was sie am meisten
lerneffekt hat ich schätze bei mir dass
ich durchaus die software auch akustisch
augen trauen kommunikative zu glauben
die serie motorisch aber kommunikativ
anzeigen haben wo sie jeder für sich
wissen oder auch hier gilt es gibt kein
besser oder schlechter
alles ist gleich wird der körper der hat
auch der körper ist ein lernort gab also
wenn es jemand notorische chips sind
dann wird er lernen auf ihren körper
viel mehr vertrag als nur auf
öffentliche wahrnehmung organe wie ohren
ist der ganze körper wahrnehmen und
lernt man sich sehr spannend finde das
in aller kürze zum thema wären töpfen
und jetzt möchte ich nicht mal zum
schluss dieser einheit hofft dass
konstruktive feedback sprechen kommt es
ist ein besonderes anliegen weil ich
schon zu beginnen sagte feedback geben
und nehmen eine kunst ist die nicht nur
im kreise der universität oder
bildungseinrichtungen von bedeutung ist
unser gesamtes leben nicht nur fürs
berufsleben auch zb eine
zwischenmenschliche angelegenheit meine
partner partnerin freund freundin sie
müssen die anderen sagen wenn sie das
stört oder wenn sie den alten kamen
kritik sei gerecht oder eine
verbesserung des seien angebracht
dann haben sich die proposition dass
diese sache nicht gut ist dass diese
sache verbessert werden so aber feedback
geben hängt nicht sehr von der position
ab dass irgendwas soundso es allgemein
wird oder eingefunden
dieses das dem anderen leben
kommuniziert hier spielt dieses sender
empfänger und der eine große rolle
und auch hier gilt es ist nicht eine
einseitige sache die vom feedbackgeber
aus geht's mit beck steht in einem
dialogischen spannungsfeld von feedback
geben
feedback nehmen als im jahr verbrauchen
wenn eine kultur des feedbacks eine
kultur des lieblings ist eine
konstruktive kultur die durch
wertschätzung und dankbarkeit gezeigt
dass das heißt derjenige der erhebung
bekommen sollte über dem ewigen von dem
antiken bekommen dankbar ist
und jetzt eben auch in der situation des
feedbacks zu kommunizieren
das heißt ein feedback nehmer reagiert
nicht nur passiv und nimmt sein dass hit
back end geben gegen st
wir kommen dem feedback blieben dennoch
auf einem gewissen weise das möchte
jetzt auch alles in allem konkretion
bisschen spazieren
ist taktgeber begeben wie macht man das
alles ist nicht ich recht effektiv das
feedback zu geben und zwar konkret
zufrieden jetzt stadt war es total
nervös dann hast du nervös was er
gezittert und du hast ja sowas zu machen
sollte man ich botschaft
die ihm auch angeben an zeigen dass es
durchaus ein subjektives urteil ist
gefällt wird
das ist immer subjektiv aus meiner sicht
also mir ist aufgefallen
und jetzt kommt der opposition dass du
deine oberkörper immer wieder von uns
geliebt hast das ist eine destruktive
proposition lass das gemacht und zwar
ganz verkleben konkrete werde zum
beispiel wir sind aufgefallen dass ab
minute 3 oder nach diesem ereignis bei
diesem punkt im seminar das sogar dass
sie das gemacht hast und du hast du das
das ist mir aufgefallen das ist erst der
erste schritt das ist einfach nur die
wartung
dann kann man nun auch was positives
noch zurückmelden und dann ist aber das
nicht geht dass man dass damit eine
konkrete realistische warum verbesserung
verbindet die man vorschlägt kann und
man sollte immer konkrete beispiele
wichtig ist es auch zu schreiben wie es
auf ein selbst gewählter also mir ist
aufgefallen dass du dein oberkörper
immer wieder fuhren zurückgewinnt hast
diese situation
das hat auf mich so gefühlt als ob du
tun sich da ist und dann kann man sagen
es wäre vielleicht
berlin ob du nicht in so einer situation
etwas gebremst einfach dein körper
berufsrecht aufrecht erhält das bringt
mehr ruhe für mich das wirkt auf mich
alles war mal ganz formal das steht auf
ihren blättern
diese bekommen habe oh warte dass du
folgende staates die so zu behandeln hat
das ist eine ganz diskret beschreibung 1
das hat auch mich so und so gehört zum
beispiel die höhe des kreativ nicht kann
auch nicht total komisch gering ist so
wird es nicht zu einer komisch ist
tendenziös ist gleich normativ oder ist
vielleicht abwertend als den antoni der
lächerlichkeit preisgeben
das hat auf mich so gewirkt als ob du
nervös ziemlich nervös und produziert
sind oder gelangweilt und dann
vielleicht ist eine für dich beim
nächsten mal beim bau zu geben
verbessert so bringt das würde auf mich
anders
das könnte wenn ich es recht verstehen
habe diese nervosität vermeiden oder das
würde ein anderes im sinn
jedenfalls
wir setzen ganz schönes person wird man
das natürlich nicht direkt machen haben
vom prinzipien dass man also immer sehr
konkret bleibt und nicht zu zerreden
also ganz wichtig ist immer ich
botschaften aussenden mir ist
aufgefallen ich habe den eindruck dass
und dann sehr exakt beschreiben dazu
gedreht werden und dann ganz
konstruktive vorschlag bringen nicht nur
bei der politik bleiben was jetzt an
eigenen augen problematischen aber auch
die kann man vergessen dass da auf der
wenige deren feedback bekommen erwartet
ebenso erwarten darf jemand der republik
gibt dass ihm derjenige in dem er das
ergibt sich öffnet und das sein dass
wertschätzung das heißt feedback die
jeweils ohne kunst feedback sollte dann
nicht als eine bedrohung ansehen
cancom mutter einst eine ja als eine
situation der charme der bloßstellung
zum feedback ist geschlossen
hier alles als feedback ist
die man setzen sollte und für die man
dankbar sein sollte und diese
dankbarkeit oder wertschätzung zweite
man auch in anderen kommunizieren und je
sind wichtiger punkt dass man nicht
versuchen sollte nicht mehr gewissen
gefahr erleben sollte sich zu
rechtfertigen sie kennt das alles kennt
jeder man bekommt und feedback mit
kritik kann auch noch das abrufen
man fühlt sich erst mal so ein bisschen
in der defensive also das habe ich
eigentlich ganz anders gemeint dass das
das stimmt ist das stimmt wird das ist
aber eigentlich war die schlechte das
ist vom feedback
mich hat oder nicht befreit sondern man
sollte es lieber einfach mal so angehen
und nicht gleich ins innenverteidigung
bilden profitiert haben
dankbarkeit aus
wenn man das porto nicht eins jeder dass
ein nicht gerechtfertigt erscheint dann
wenn es nachfragen sicherlich der
sinnvolle wege und missverständnisse was
meinst du genau mit und mit körper vor
und zurückbewegen unter langem ein
begriff
[Musik]
also die frage was meinst du mit ist
aufforderung des jahres vergibt sachlich
zusagen des effektivsten wenn jetzt sehr
viel mehr gebe sagte du mir ist
aufgefallen so thaler erst dann könnten
sie als feedback nehmen und sagen was
meinst du mit total nervös und dann
müsste der eine in der das feedback gibt
sagen du bist leben nach vorne hin
du bist ständig hin und her oder du hast
irgendwie deine arbeit verschränkt und
den teilnehmern ist also frage nach
konkreten zurück das ist ganz ganz
wichtig ja aber jetzt gibt sie auch
dieses schema das ist ganz wichtig alles
wieder so ein akronym danach folgt eben
auch das feedback als beschreibung einer
beobachtung interpretation als ich habe
gesehen dass mit körper nach vorne
hinten gekippt wird
das habe ich so interpretiert als orbit
uhr begrüßen
das heißt und ich würde dir empfehlen
das nicht zu machen so das ist nicht
wirkt sie nicht nur aus so und am
schluss nicht vergessen konstruktive
verbesserungen
an deiner stelle würde ich mit so einer
situation das oder sie kennen das
beispiel jemand hat die hände der
hosentasche also ich habe festgestellt
dass du die ende der großen taschen ist
in dieser phase das hat auch nicht so
gefühlt als ob gelangweilt gewesen wärst
und das kam nicht postführung habe ich
mich als teilnehmer so bist du nicht so
wertgeschätzt gefühlt aber ich würde
vorstellen vorstellen dass du einfach
mit den händen eine andere geste eines
nämlich zum beispiel da kommen als
kleine dorf die hände geben
euro aus der hosentasche herausstellt
kann man auch noch machen ist kein
problem mit dem verschenken richtig
ganze zeit zum mitnehmen hier bist du
nun steht merkel heute zu machen die
haben wir in den spielen so also soviel
zum thema gegeben ich hoffe ich und
jugend sieht das jetzt nicht alter mann
soll dessen erscheinen jetzt kaum zur
wirkung des sprechens das ist deswegen
wichtig weil wir gesehen haben der
auditive typ sehr sehr wichtig ist ist
die akustik die information über das
gefühlszentrum jetzt kommen die drei
bekannten unterscheidung die ich ihnen
schon
niemand hatte die sprachlichen ebene
dann die stimme ich ein paar werte neben
der sprachlichen und das ist auch ein
der allerwichtigsten bescheidung ergibt
dies zu behaupten und gibt im
zwischenmenschlichen bereich
jetzt muss man das noch kurz klären was
es genau ist dabei stellen muss als
immer versuchen wenn man kommuniziert
diese drei ebenen global para verbal zu
betrachten also zb gehen wir noch ein
bisschen zurück die sprachliche ebene
ist zb das weiß ich jetzt keine trennung
ich rede den wörther ich spreche wort
aus und kommuniziere semantisch gericht
zu gehen vergeblich artikulieren wörter
sprachliche zeichnen werden akustisch
vermittelt dass die sprachliche werden
jetzt geht sie stimmlich aber wer wollte
das ist zum beispiel die geschwindigkeit
mit der ich rede die gleichen
informationen kommt mit ziehen
ich kann schneller oder langsamer
kommunizieren ich kann auch leise oder
laut kommunizieren je nach situation die
nativen wenn mir das müssen das wichtig
ist werde ich vielleicht mehr betonung
oder auch meine niederhalten um diesen
begriff mehr bedeutung wenn es um etwas
ihre nebensächliches geht kann ich das
muss schneller und billiger
kaiser und munition ohne so vieles getan
das heißt sie können die informationen
auch bestimmen indem sie eben paravent
faktoren mit einfließen lassen
im hause ist die tor melodie und so weit
es geht die post
da müssen wir zu den größten fragen und
naturwissenschaften dass eine ganze
wissenschaft für sich wie viele
parameter dass da gibt die die parade
geben bestimmen 100 sollte sich dieser
faktoren bewusstsein sie können also
bewusst durch pfarrer verbale
kommunikation informationen steuerung
immer darauf achten es gibt ganz
verschiedene dimensionen der
kommunikation die nicht nur das
gesprochene wort betreffen und zum
schluss sind es ist mein lieblingsfach
steht lieben die körper sprachlichen und
wirkte ebene und das betrifft eben alles
was nicht gesprochen ist nicht
artikulieren staatlichen organe also zum
beispiel wie sie dastehen passiert die
schwenkt habe oder ob sie beim digital
über anschauen oder ob es den blick
senken ob sie die tafel und die warten
schon
wie sie im raum stehen ist die probleme
das ist total nähern firmen
das ist alles so die hände der
hosentasche
das sind alles körpersprachlich
kommunikationsformen diese zwölf tiere
ist sie mit tiere bei tieren sieht man
dass noch viel exakter wenn eine katze
und ein bisschen druck kann man daraus
schließen dass sie jetzt sagen wir diese
emotion hat angst vor ich zeigte durch
körperliche vereins ist achtet sie
darauf alle drei ebenen die machen viel
der kommunikation also verschiedenen
ebenen können sie ansetzen und
sprachlicher ausdruck ist auch noch ein
wichtiger punkt dass sie als auch wenn
sie es eine der vollstreckung geben dass
sie nicht zu viele fremdwörter benutzten
als möglichst verständlich eben sind
natürlich gibt es in akademischen
kreisen schon die gepflogenheit etwas
mehr fachbegriffe zu verwenden wir
müssen eben auch auf fachbegriffe
regulierend jetzt nicht auch schon mal
eben so eine kohärenz schon wieder so zu
erreichen aber manchmal sagen einfach
unglaublich muss man sich überlegen wie
er gleich die best verständlichen effekt
schade die beispiele zu geben oder auch
zu visualisieren positive verbindung
positive formulierungen verwenden also
direkt formuliert
ich botschaften formulieren und auch gut
das macht die ganze sache anschaulicher
und na ja mit diesem manchmal mehr ist
seine sache sie kennen den glücklichsten
weichmacher und diesen zum lesen sie
wieder heißt sehr gut aber es gibt noch
besseren eigentlich hab nur 37 wissen
sie einem weichmacher der 14
er ist allerdings zugleich es gibt auch
noch sozusagen ein
auch hier sehen aber theoretisch ist als
sonst der nehme diesen wagen ist der
dass einem dieses wort eine freiheit
gibt noch mal nachzudenken
sie können das wort sozusagen für jedes
andere wort einsatzstellen ich meine es
sozusagen das haben sie vier sind in
diesen vier silben diese gespräche
können sie nochmal nachlegen
den rest des satzes noch mal besser
formulieren ich bin eigentlich der
meinung reich machen kann man durchaus
zu finden
es gab mal so ein test den wir gemacht
haben dann haben wir mal versucht ganz
auf gehalt zu verzichten auch auf solche
erfüllen lautet dass die kommunikation
oder nicht besser
also die historische stoff das studio
ermitteln was etwas im reibung
befindliches setzte wieder zum kleid
bringen da wäre ich mir nicht so viele
gedanken auch wenn sie jetzt aber ebenso
ein bisschen internet haben zu häufig
eines diese worte zu verwenden
schauen sie ob sie nicht vielleicht ein
bisschen andere wirkung
das werden wir auch nach dem ende dieser
faktoren schon museen wenn wir dieses
freiwillige video weg machen dann können
sie auch mal schauen zu kommen satzbau
natürlich einfacher selbst besser als
komplexes ich habe etwas zu lange sätze
zu formulieren
das ist geschmackssache aktivisten sind
besser als passive prosieben wir schon
davor sagen die register indirekte
vorstellung betrachten immer mit dem zug
liegt anfangen ich er ist werde objekt
das die bessere direktorin eine gängige
formulierung ja dieser film heute hatten
wir schon ein bisschen schnell mit
quasi in der mitte und kann sie
verwenden haben wir solche sie
reflektieren sollten bewusst
das sind ja so werden statt 1000 oft
gebraucht aber ja ich bin mir nicht ganz
sicher ob das zu stimmen das sind das
schnell bearbeiten die informationen
verhindern aber dann bin ich ein
bisschen das werden schloss kennen ja
losgehen sind auch schmiermittel wenn
sie ebenso häufig verwendet werden
thematisch der stimmliche ausdruck dass
also jetzt die parabel mal eben er ist
auch ganz wichtig betont das ist nicht
der grund sie müssen bedenken sie nur
die aufmerksamkeit immer teilnehmern
fesselten sie wollen sich die
aufmerksamkeit sicher sein
das setzt vom aus der sie auch in der
para verbalen ebene was zufrieden haben
dass sie nicht immer nur auf einer
tonhöhe artikulieren sind dass sie
durchaus nicht mehr ganz zu lassen
wichtig ist auch unwichtig unterscheiden
indem es ihnen
es geht einfach eine performative
dimension ihrer kommen dazu artikulation
deutlichkeit ist klar das muss an
gesprächen nicht zu schnell sprechender
mann aufgeregt ist redet wo manchmal zu
schnell
gönnen sie sich mit tausenden gerade der
philosophie nach dingen zwischen den
sätzen das nicht schlecht sprechtempo
authentizität lautstärke natürlich im
lautstärke das mächtige punkt setzt auch
voraus dass sich davor mit dem raum und
seiner akustischen eigenschaften
vertraut gemacht haben wie halt der raum
für alle musiker ist es besonders
wichtig die akustik ist sprechen zimmer
in dem raum wo man leider sagen sie mal
was laut hören sie mal wieder so nach
klickt hier sind selbst sehr viel hall
ist dieser traum kann auch renate muss
man alles körper sprachliche ausdruck
das ist jetzt also die verbale
kommunikation der können
ich habe mich schon ein bisschen vorweg
gegriffen hat ist offen unterhaltung der
ich sag mal so viel mehr gebaut ist der
erste schritt der erst anfang der auf
und gut aber es ist noch nicht das ende
der fahnenstange beginnen
aber man kann sich durchaus von diesem
luxus und diesen ansatz etwas
weiterentwickeln möchte aber es ist
besser als die hände immer in der
hosentasche
das ist schon was sehr wichtig sind aber
was ich empfehle anstatt deren märkte
ist sich ein gegenstand zum leben zum
beispiel ein solcher fernbedienungen wo
das stift und den zehn einer hand
dadurch dass hier genießt das gewicht
wiegt neid und dazu die hände nicht zu
hoch zu halten nicht zu tief zu halten
seien ebenfalls damit habe ich irgendwas
in die hand zu geben damit nicht zu viel
um zu spielen das kann dann wieder
nervös wirken aber so ein bisschen was
sie der hand zwischenzeitig habe damals
oder hinter auf der grundhaltung
also parallel und eben auch handflächen
nach oben hier riecht also mehr sein -
meeres zeichen wenn ich die handflächen
dem anderen beamten symbolisiere ich
damit ich habe nichts zu verbergen
nämlich die hände der borussen tasche
haben da können durch eine pistole oder
messer oder sonst was tun haben wenn ich
die hände des uralt ist klar ja nichts
zu verbergen
auch in der kommunikation die offenen an
flächen werden so gedeutet dass man
ehrlich ist dass jemand klar
kommuniziert dass also ganz wichtig
oberhalb der körpermitte gestikulierende
finde ich auch wichtig also gürtellinie
und drüber nicht unter der gürtellinie
kommunizieren und ja dann blinkt
sogenannte aktoren das war das was es
sagt mit den rundenspielen als hier der
fernbedienung ständig den stift treiber
termine aus und einfahren oder sowas
oder mit an um irgendwelche komischen
figuren danach oder sowas
mit dem ringen spielen oder sonstwas
polizist kaum noch ein wichtiger punkt
ist beobachte ich auch an der bahn den
menschen wenn man etwas unsicher ist
greift man sich manchmal zum hals so
dass ich will nicht sagen das ist falsch
aber sie sollten sich dessen bewusst
sein wie es auch gehen wenn sie es so
machen
das ist ein zeichen dass immer jemand an
die gurgel bild sitzt die zeit der
unsicherheit und es spricht nichts
dagegen die hände zu verschränken warum
ich weil sie oberhalb der körper
ich sage ich gäste kombinieren aber
kommunizieren diese haltung ist kann das
bedeuten haben sie die idee wenn ich
jetzt nicht so hinstellen es hat zwei
dort mindestens nun werden das wird es
verschlossen und verschlossen genau als
zum beispiel wäre verschlossen wenn ich
so stünde mit den beiden vielleicht
parallel wenn ich jetzt aber solche bei
einer aufnahme über kreuz
das könnte es dann doch der teuren mich
ein bisschen zurücklehnen ja oder
entspannt wenn die arme sind ja auch
schwer
man möchte man bisher entlastet es
könnte eben auch eine entspannte aus dem
zug und deswegen arme verschränkt ist
nicht als solches schon schlecht oder
dem blickkontakt ganz wichtig alle regen
der druckerei beziehen nicht immer nur
eine person anschauen alle version dann
schon nicht so aufdringlich anschauen
aber immer mal wieder eines blickes
würdigen
dann gibt es wenn sie mit mehreren
leuten kommunizieren zum beispiel großen
vorlesungen oder seminaren wo sie nicht
nur den einzelnen überblickende sondern
wo sie wirklich 50 60 jahren da kann man
zurückblickt machen als praktisch sofort
wo sie von ganz hinten auffordern oder
zurückblicken wir sind für eine andere
behandlung starb zu überlegen wo das gmw
blick als praktisch hier seien m legen
und dann noch ein beet rüber sind ihre
gegen gesetzt damit sie alle ab denke
das ist wichtig das ganze publikum
möchte ich gedacht sind auch belegt
werden körperhaltung offen der gruppe
zugewandt haben flächen aufrecht das
sicherer stand immer so ein bisschen für
sich die beiden natürlich nicht
pander ist öffnet und nicht zu weit und
spart geben oder hast du halt sondern
auch nicht zu steigern so ein bisschen
auch nichts dass er in die kinos ein
bisschen halt flexibel sein
bewegung im raum auch ein wichtiger rom
verbaler faktoren genannt bewegen
bewusst einsetzen also dürfen und gerne
auch mal auf die gruppe zu geben
natürlich nicht so als ob sie betreuen
wird damit ein bisschen zu werden mit
dem zurückgehen wenn sie zb zwei
verschiedenen positionen abwägen wollen
dann können sie durchaus symbolisieren
dass eine position die position der türe
ist und die andere position die position
des 1
das heißt wenn sie von der eigenen
position aufgehört darum zu reden wie
jetzt mit events davon wird erlauben die
zwei anderen pose zu begleiten damit
können sie auch gewisse schwere ruhige
bewegungen sind wichtig nicht zu viel
bewegung das kann ruhig wirken zu wenige
bildung bewegung kann der starren
drücken
keine barrieren zwischen dem publikum
und sangen der tischreihe so einfach
offenes verhältnis
die körpersprache wird vom publikum
unbewusst gedauert und es werden viele
botschaften aus die herausgabe ist oft
manifestieren ist eine bestimmte
einstellung im körperlichen eindruck das
ist eben würde die eigene einstellung zu
hinterfragen und gegebenenfalls zu
ändern als einem anderen verwirklichen
ist darauf zu setzen
dazu gibt eben auch diese videos und wir
heute fahren ja das war es dann
in diesem teil und ich verabschiede mich
wenn wir sehen uns einem weiteren video
einem weitern die halb stream demnächst
zum thema stimme und haltungen und
diskussionen bleiben das werden auch der
dienste leisten heute gewesen